[Music]
thanks for coming to this talk
my name is Hotel Soraka I'm a developer
relations engineer at Google working on
Android
my name is Z Dwyer I'm an engineer in
the Android toolkit team and today we're
going to talk about live data live data
is one of the first architecture
components that we released last year
and in this talk we're going to explain
what it is we're going to talk about
some of the transformations that you can
do how to combine live data and then
we're going to talk about some patterns
and anti patterns that you might want to
avoid so like data is a simple life
cycle where observable data folder we're
going to explain all these
characteristics but first we're going to
start with observable what's an
observable so in our object-oriented
world probably the easiest way of
communicating one component and another
is by having a reference from one object
to another and just call it directly
however in Android this might have some
problems as we all know components in
Android have different life cycles and
different life spans you might be
familiar with this diagram it's the view
model scope diagram a simple thing like
a device rotation can actually recreate
the activity so you probably know that
having an reference to activity in this
view model would be a bad idea because
it leads to memory leaks even crashes
with no pointer exceptions so instead of
having a reference to the activity in
the view model we're gonna try to have a
reference to the view model in the
activity so how do we communicate how do
we send data from the view model to the
activity one instead of doing that we're
going to let the activity observe the
view the view model and for that we're
going to use observables like data let's
see how this looks with a little bit of
code in the view model we expose our
live data where you're going you're
going to see a lot of examples of how to
expose live data from a view model
and then in our activity we make the
actual subscription and we do that by
calling the observe method on the
observable the first parameter is
something called a lifecycle owner it is
going to talk about this in a second and
the second parameter is an observer this
is what's called whenever the observable
the live data the live data is value is
changed so hoes I mentioned that you
want to reference an object in the
larger scope like a V model from an
object in a smaller scope like an
activity but of course when you observe
something it has to keep a reference
back to you to be able to call it so
there is a reference but why is this not
a problem it like that well light it is
and life cycle every component what do
you mean by this to able to observe a
live data you have to provide a life
cycle and when you provide this life
cycle
it basically maintains your subscription
for you for free so if your observers
life cycle is not in a good state like a
stopped activity it's not going to call
you back or when your activity or
fragment is destroyed is going to remove
this subscription automatically for you
so you don't have the burden of
maintaining this subscription so if you
go back to the previous graph your light
weight of the world will only be cold if
it is between started and before it is
stopped this make sure you don't need to
care about things like fragment
transactions once you receive observable
value you know you're in a good state
probably the most like distinctive
property of life data is that is that
data holder so it's not a stream we keep
saying this but what I mean by that like
is not a stream pass the value holder if
you go back to our previous graphs on
the right we have a live data in our
view model and on the Left we have our
activity or fragment that's observing
this live data once you set a value on
the live data just values pass to the
activity similarly if the value changes
the activity receive
the new updated value but the difference
happens when you change the value when
the observer is not in an active state
it means it has no idea that value C is
never dispatch to the activity and let's
say while your activities still have a
background thread oh sorry in the
background the thread
you said the new value and your activity
still doesn't see this now the data
older property comes in now when your
activity comes back but user Singh is in
the foreground
it receives the latest value from the
wheel model as you can see the value C
has never a right to the activity
because light it only cares about
holding a single value and it's the
latest value this works perfect for UI
because you only want to show what it is
right now but if you are trying to
process a stream of events this is not
what you're looking for similarly if you
change the value after activities
destroyed nothing happens okay let's
talk about how to combine live data and
talk about transformations the library
provides to map and switch map but you
can create your own using mediator live
data we already said that live data is
great to communicate view and a view
model but what if we have a third
component maybe a repository that is
also exposing a live data how do we make
this subscription from the view model we
don't have a life cycle there what if
the app is even more complicated and the
repository is also observing data
sources in this case well eat one said
to me that if you need a life cycle in
your view model what do you really want
you probably need a transformation but
it's actually wrong
sorry eight so you know what I say is
that you definitely need a
transformation don't ever use a
lifecycle in your view model so
different flower so okay how do we make
the first sample is a bridge between the
view and the repository how do we get to
that live data we use of transformations
map which is what I call a one-to-one
static transformation in the view model
we expose a view a live data in this
case it's called view model result and
it's a result of a transformations map
the first parameter is the source the
live data source which is a live data
exposed by the repository and the second
parameter is a transformation function
in this case it's simply converting from
the data layer model to the UI model and
this is how the signature would look
like in Kotlin it has source which is a
live data of X and it returns a live
data Y so it's a breach of like datas
and then in the in the middle we have a
transformation function that transforms
from X to Y it doesn't know anything
about live data so when you establish
that transformation the key here is that
the lifecycle is automatically carried
over for you
so say you run a transformation of a
couple of live data's and at the end it
is a live data that you hold on to when
someone subscribes to it that lifecycle
is automatically propagated to the inner
live data elements without you doing
anything and it's completely managed by
us so it's completely safe another
transformation we provide is switch map
so when do we need this imagine you have
an application where you have a user
measure that keeps a log the user ID is
somewhere like a disc and whenever that
block the user ID when you grab it you
need to talk to your user repository to
get the actual user object and that
probably goes to the database and also
the server to return you this user
object but that repository turns your
live data as well because user object
might change right it may return
the cash fun violate updates from the
server so your initiation where you have
a light off a log the user ID and I like
that of a user and you need to chain
these things so networks if you are
changing from an idea to a user but how
do we change from an idea to a live date
of a user that's switch map so if you
look at the that example basically we
call switch memory provided this user ID
live data that's a live data and then
our function this time returns a live
data so the signature looks like this
you have a source and at the end you
have a live data and you provide a
function that converse converts the well
your ex to a live data what this
technically does is every time that user
ID changes it calls your function you
give it a live live data it R subscribes
from the previous live data your
research and that subscribes to the name
it's like switching tracks or I think
it's comes from like switchboards but
it's completely managed for you and it's
still life cycle ever you get all the
benefits of using live data now we only
provide map a switch map we don't have
like a million transformations like some
some other libraries the but this is
very limiting and sometimes you may want
to write your own and we actually don't
want to provide many but if you want to
write your own it's very easy if I show
you our like little the code we have for
the map implementation that was a total
what it does the see resource and it
does return the live data and you give
it a function right all it does is
creates this mediator live data class
and adds the given source as a source
for this mediator live data what in
which it kind of tells us that the value
of this mediator live data is derived
from this other live data so whenever
that other line data changes call my
callback and in the callback we
basically apply the function to the
value and set as a value on the mediator
live data this is like super simple to
write and there is no life cycle here
but all of this code is life cycle area
so if it's so easy let's create a new
one let's say we want to create
something about users filling your form
you have a bunch of strings and you want
to have the total card showing somewhere
so you have a live data and a lender lie
data and you basically have a lie date
of integer that has the total number of
characters in those li'dat elements and
this integer updates if any of those
values updates so we called our faction
total line we receive a list of life
datas and we returned a line data what
we do here is we have a sum function
it's actually very simple it goes
through all of the live data and sums
their length we need to account for
nulls here because why data allows now
so you need to be aware of it but this
is very simple it's basically look at
all the live data values and sum total
length once we did that we add each
given live data as a source store
mediator which basically says the value
of this mediator depends on these other
live data so anytime any of them changes
the frame rate calls back I will do some
function which calculates the new value
for the mediator live data and this is
it it's like four lines of code and you
have a operation a transformation or
your light data's now there are some
common mistakes you can make while using
live data and want to touch base on
these things what one thing we see a lot
is let's say you have you make a web
request it returns a giant jason and
then you're converted to your objects
using a live data transformation for
doing that is not a good idea because
light it is a value holders so the
launch string your fish from your server
is going to stay in memory it's going to
hold on to that so you probably don't
want to use live data for something like
that it's not just we there's a one-shot
operation okay the second item is about
sharing instances of live data at one
point I was trying to make an app with
live data and I had a repository that
was a singleton and it was only one
observer in the activity
so I said okay I can just save some like
data's
and share a single life data I had
something like this repository it takes
a data source and then the mutable life
data that we are returning in load item
is shared by everyone that calls load
item now this is fine it works but
there's a very interesting edge case and
this this anti-pattern is about you
thinking which observers are going to be
active and the edge case is activity
transitions there is this case in
Android where two activities are going
to be active at the same time so imagine
activity one observes item number one an
activity to observes item number two
when we load activity two is going to
load data for item two but because they
are sharing the same life data activity
one is also going to receive that data
and because it's in the middle of an
animation you're gonna see a flash you
can see a glitch and obviously that's a
very bad user experience
yeah basic like class like a poster and
you created a field that's an instance
of life data you're probably doing it
wrong yeah the solution obviously is to
create a life data every time it's very
lightweight you're not going to save
much by avoiding this the third item is
about where and when to create your
transformations and this is all about
wiring it's similar to when you create a
circuit you lay down your components and
you wire everything up and for a known
set of inputs you're going to have an
own set of outputs but you don't unplug
a wire while it's in operation and plug
it somewhere else right this is exactly
what this view model is doing lots of
horrible things happening in this view
model by wait for it for starters don't
do this in this slide it's literally
someone will copy past it and then blame
us for recommending it that's the
standard way of doing it so first it's
exposing item data which is a variable
it's not a vowel it's a vow
and also it's exposing immutable life
data almost you should almost never do
this two-way data-binding is the
exception to this maybe you should
always expose something that is
immutable so that our your observers
can't change it
so after subscription we call load data
from our activity to set the ID of the
thing that we want to load and then we
are reassigning item data to something
new but the subscription already
happened so the observer is not going to
know that you made this reassignment the
solution like actually even if you're
returning the light data' there and your
observers subscribe like that' now it is
subscribed to the previous one and the
new one because you never remove the
subscription so the solution to this
requires a little bit of plumbing we
have to like datas one is mutable and
it's private to this view model and the
other one is the one that is exposed to
the view from the view model and it is a
transformation switch map the source of
this rich map is that mutable live data
so that every time item ID changes then
the transformation function is going to
be called and datasource which returns
the live data is going to be called with
the appropriate ID after the
subscription to this item data has
happened we call low data we pass the
string this ID might come from an intent
in the activity or whatever and then
when we set the value then it triggers
an update and everything is going to
work as you expect it to work ok so you
would like to think that light it is
assumed and it solves all the problems
it doesn't it's designed for a very
specific use case we see people trying
to use it in other areas and they they
struggle with it so I want to make it
clear if you're writing an application
that has lots of like operators and
streams you've totally bought into this
reactive idea just use rx Java I don't
try to add like a million
transformations on top of light data to
make it or it's not
designed for that golden eggs if you
have things that are not related to a
life cycle or a UI let's say you are
trying to synchronize the user's
location to your back-end service there
is no UI there there's no life cycle
there like there is no reason to use
white data for something like that
you do use a callback or if you're using
Excel that was to work another use case
is having these like one-shot operations
like mention you face some data and then
you converted you right into your
database load back and return it for
those things if you're using Copelan
coroutines are actually like a really
neat new exciting area again you might
use global concurrent or you can use or
extra but don't use live data because we
didn't design it or that live data works
very well is the last layer for your UI
it's perfectly okay and it's a kind of
the best solution but if you try to
scale it it's just not going to work so
many things we mentioned in this dog
actually Rosa has blog post on the
Android developers medium publishing you
can go read them I check out our samples
on github we have simple usages of live
data as well as a complete application
the github browser sample with like
using room has like multiple data
sources transformations and also you can
look at the source code for i/o
scheduler
which is the same app in their summit
and if it has bugs you can blame this
guy he wrote it yeah thank you very much
for coming I hope this was useful and we
will be in the area like around after
the talks thank you thank you
[Music]